- Hi everybody!
Guess what day it is?
- Monday.
- Monday!
It's the day to get it done.
I can tell you I need to go on a cleanse
because yeah, it was, the weekend.
my daughter, it was her eighth birthday.
(crowd cheers)
And she's actually here right now.
My kids are here at work
with me, which is so amazing.
They have the day off school
and we'll see how this goes.
I'm so excited.
I love you guys so much.
My daughter turned eight this weekend.
Eight! Eight.
Eight.
I mean, when people say
that it goes by so fast,
I feel like it's usually
people who are kind
of on the other side of it,
like looking in the rear view mirror
and they really know
how fast it does go by.
They're trying to warn you to be present,
but when you're in it,
the truth is it's more
like the Yiddish proverb
that the days are long
and the years are short.
And when you're looking
back at the scrapbook
of your life it seems like an instant,
but I know right now being a parent is one
of the hardest things, the most rewarding,
but we're all trying to be super heroes.
And, you know, I had this amazing weekend
where I felt like finally for, you know
launching this show, I
had like the perfect kid
to life ratio and I was just all in
and I knew exactly what my
priorities were in life.
And it just felt so good.
Happy birthday, Olive.
(crowd cheers)
Cheers to being eight.
Cheers to me realizing I can't get away
with eating all that
leftover birthday cake
and the macaroni and cheese
and everything else that I had,
I mean, just, I went on a food bender
and so yeah, I'm gonna be
cleansing this week a little bit.
But listen, whether your motherhood
or as I love to call it other-hood,
I think one of the things
that's really being taught
to us right now in this wild
journey is to be present.
And although time has stopped,
literally it's just stopped.
We can't will that clock
to move any faster.
We can try to be present together
and appreciate anything
and everything around us.
In fact, Jasmine from Chicago,
I think you have your kids right?
- Yes. Yes, I have four.
- Oh my gosh.
How are you juggling four?
- I have no idea, but you know what,
it's like you said, we're
enjoying the journey.
It is an absolute blessing.
- It really is.
I had this like call with
the show this weekend
and we were just talking
about kids in this time
and we haven't lived like
this in a hundred years.
All our societal norms
and agreements are gone.
Work, school.
- Yep.
- Everything's different.
And I know how trying that is.
And yet when I just let everything else go
and focus solely on my kids this weekend,
I knew what the purpose of my life was.
And it was so wonderful.
But you don't have to
be a parent for that.
Like just finding something, someone,
that gives you the meaning and the reason.
- Yeah, yes.
- You have four.
- Yes, yes. Four beautiful babies.
I wouldn't have it any other way.
Our life is complete. My heart is full.
- Aw, cheers to you, Jasmine.
Thank you for,
we can back each other
up on finding that love
and goodness in life and just
holding onto it for dear life!
- Yes!
- Thanks Jasmine,
cheers to you this morning.
All right, we have a great show.
We're gonna kick it off
with one of the classiest
women on the planet.
The most extraordinary talent,
Julianne Moore is here.
More and more and more,
look at her! Oh my goodness!
All right, and we're
gonna start with the news
as we like to serve it sunny side up,
it's time for Drew's News.
(glass shattering)
(cat screeches)
Ma'am, I asked you a question!
It's Drew's News!
Hi everybody! Walking to the news desk.
All right, on Drew's News,
we find all of those good morsels
that carry us throughout the day.
And I love this section of the show
because I have so much
fun with the news crew,
the best people in the world.
And we comb through for
these life affirming stories
of our country and the people in it.
So we're actually shooting our
show here in New York City.
And lately the restaurants
have been shifting
to outdoor dining and New
York City has felt more
like gay Paris and I love it.
The New York Times reports
that the mayor has said
the outdoor dining theme
will continue year round.
(crowd cheers)
I know!
I mean, it is pretty wild
when you live somewhere
and everything changes overnight
and the changes are positive.
And then they're gonna stay.
And New York has really felt
like a bustling European city
and I'm so excited for
the island of Manhattan
to have a renaissance.
Aha, I'm going to have
a bagel after the show
and I'm gonna have it al fresco.
(crowd cheers)
In other news,
Vogue magazine has Lizzo on the cover
and I just love her so much.
She looks exceptional on
this cover, like flawless.
And in this article she
talks about body positivity
is not even enough.
She would like it to be body normative.
She wants to normalize her body
and she's a huge advocate
of the no filter beauty.
And I am a big proponent of that as well.
And she's doing it in her
way and we love her for that.
And we cheer her on endlessly
because you have to be your
authentic self in this world.
Sometimes that's all we have.
So yay, Lizzo. We love you here so much.
Everybody loves her.
Okay, let's talk about some
more women who are crushing it.
This story is everywhere right now.
Okay, this female surfer
rode the biggest wave
of the year and shattered
a Guinness World Record.
I know. Wait until you see this.
I mean, do we have footage?
She's a surfer from Brazil.
Yeah. There you go.
Named Maya Gabeira.
And scientists say the wave
was basically 74 feet tall.
That's two telephone
poles on top of each other
or five giraffes high.
And what even makes this more inspiring is
that in 2013, Maya had an
accident, a near death crash
from a 50 foot wave,
not even nearly as big,
and it took her four years to
recover from it, but she did.
And now she's back, okay?
She's getting back up
on that old wave horse,
#TheOldWaveHorse, and
she's riding the biggest,
baddest waves in the world.
Now, wow.
If that isn't a way to
show how you get back up,
I don't know what is.
Thank you Maya for
showing us how it's done.
(crowd cheers)
Okay, whoop, whoop!
It's time for a beauty junkie alert.
All right. I'm really
into this next story.
And this goes out to all the
chins out there, all right.
Are you sick and tired of mask-ne,
which is acne and what
comes from under your mask?
You heard me.
Marie Claire has posted a
new soothing facial mask
that fits underneath your PPE.
It's called the Soothe &
Shield mask by Masque Bar
and it uses aloe and natural oils.
I actually love even taking
a little aloe vera plant,
I'm from California,
so this is what we do.
We go and hack a little thing off.
And then you use the
natural aloe on your face.
It's an amazing hack.
And they sell them at
bodega's all around the city
and you can find them, you can plant them.
Aloe vera is very easily
available where they have like
the herbs and stuff at your
local shops, it's there.
And so you put this underneath your mask
and listen, we can't protect
ourselves enough, you know,
from COVID, and then this
can help you with your acne
and dry skin.
And it's a winnie win win
for the chinny chin chin
(upbeat music)